move over justice league see a later
marvel
hey you're looking for those infinity
stones
you got yourself a gauntlet thanos
there's only one person
more powerful than all of those
characters put together
and that's sister gene what up everybody
i
am adam lefkow and this is calling all
takes
brought to you by coors light now i'm
warning you
these march hoop takes they are coming
in hot
so stay cool with refreshing coors light
during the games
[Music]
what is going on it is lefko and it is
time
to hear your hottest takes college
basketball we're getting ready to crown
a champion
and we are gonna put your takes right
here and we're gonna see how hot they
are
first one let's check it out not one
single one seed will make the final
weekend you heard it here first
benny by real benny
you crazy i'm not a big fan of this take
why
because gonzaga has not lost a single
game
and they've been beating everybody by
seemingly
50 points in every game are you not a
big fan of baylor
i i am i get it are you looking at
michigan and you're seeing those
injuries and you're kind of doubting
them
i get that too did you see illinois go
down and you're like hey
that's the reason i'm confident benny
it's a
pretty hot take on the kelvin scale
it's about a five i'm not sure if that's
how they measure kelvins
but it's a hot take it's a hot take i
just don't think it's a great take
tyrell 27 charles barkley won't guess
one game right for the rest of the
tourney sorry chuck
a guarantee that you are wrong
i think it's a popular take i think it's
something that people
love to say oh charles barkley doesn't
know what he's talking about
he's got to get one right just like you
got at least one wrong with your
tournament
so i think it'll be a popular take but
not a hot take i'm giving it a three
the real chris w bees up
jay wright and nova nation are about to
cut down the nets for the third
time call chris jenkins top of the key
north carolina
squidoosh they've cut that they've got
that arch
magic so they're talking about ryan
archie diacono who is now on the chicago
bulls and his younger brother who is
on the team and that energy is coming
together look
i'm looking at their part of the
tournament
they're taking on baylor if they beat
baylor
they have absolutely a chance because of
the upsets on the other part
of their tournament so you got oral
roberts on the bottom half there
houston's the best team available so i
look at villanova
i think with jay wright the culture they
got there good chance
i don't think it's gonna happen so i'm
giving it a six
all right our next take is from ooh
goody let's see if this is an ooh goody
one
oral roberts is going to the
final weekend within a game of the
championship
oral roberts it's a hot taco goody hot
tape
so our first little foursome of takes
they were hot they were spicy if i had
to pick my favorite
probably that noble one in case you
don't know
i'm adam lefkow l-e-f-k-o-e
man we've been putting takes right here
about college basketball and who you
think is going to win the tournament
and we're rating them from mild to super
spicy
let's keep those takes coming in next up
who do we got
sister gene has magical powers and is
not to be bet against under
any circumstance nora joy318
nora you just said my absolute
favorite tape because i believe move
over justice league
see a later marvel hey
you're looking for those infinity stones
you got yourself a
gauntlet thanos there's only one person
more
powerful than all of those characters
put together and that's sister gene
and i'm just saying that if loyola
chicago is playing on a sunday
i'm not betting against a 101 year old
saint
okay that right there was my number one
take cameron krutwig will be the
tournament most outstanding player
and the best mustache sager power that's
a shout out to
craig sager shout out to you cameron
crutwig
looks like josh allen from the buffalo
bills
if he went to loyola i think that he
reminds me of kevin
pitsnoggle from back in the day that was
on west virginia
um but i think he's really exciting him
winning most outstanding player
i am going to say is it likely to happen
if we're doing loyola takes i'm taking
sister
gene all right let's get to the next one
because sager power had a good one next
is going to be
j tay ray my best buddy buddy behind's
march
greater than greater than buddy healed's
march and it's not even
close okay for those that don't remember
buddy hill played for oklahoma dropped
37 on oregon was amazing
buddy beijing son of jim beiheim guess
who went to syracuse
this guy he is looking like uh
the eighth man on an nba team right now
that hits like a big three gets a
tap on the head from lebron uh i think
that buddy beyheim has made me proud
i look at their part of the tournament
if they take down houston
buddy beijing could make a run but buddy
hill was special but
thanks for playing to my syracuse fandom
i really appreciate it
eight dog two two three gonzaga runs the
table and wins
every game by at least 10 goat college
team this is the kelly blue book
take of the week good value strong base
nice support good gas mileage gonzaga is
the team that
everybody knows that they should pick to
win but they don't
because they're trying to win the
tournament against their friends so
i look at this with gonzaga they've been
the best team in bat
in in basketball we haven't seen a team
go undefeated and run the table since
1976 with indiana
mark few and the bulldogs looking like
they could be the team
that gets it done by 10 is what makes it
spicy
this feels like the most ballot of the
hot takes that felt
really really strong now we are going to
dan yee
or as i'm gonna pronounce it daniel 33
by the way
33 amazing number michigan
mason blue will save my picks and the
conference
and win it all don't know about your
picks daniel
but the conference nine teams came in
michigan's the only one remaining
all right the takes they are a common
uh it could be m cecil
but i'm gonna go with mcgeckel
mcgeckle31
having the whole tournament in indy has
been
dope i think they should have it in one
location
every year to that i go i'm sorry
you just got the worst take of the day
why
as someone that has covered the
tournament and i have gone from city to
city
here's the reason mceckel because i have
covered the tournament
and there's something about watching a
fan base
take over a city i saw it in tucson
i saw it in austin there's something
about
watching all the alabama fans go up to
new york
and watching all the illinois fans go
out to santa fe
and watch them turn that city into their
team's colors and
fill up the arenas and give it that
passion
i miss the fans i also think that's a
huge reason why these
better teams supposedly are losing to
all these smaller teams
is because all of the fans are not there
so it's been convenient
indianapolis has done an incredible job
they do great with every sporting event
but definitely with this one but there
is something missing
and i wish that we could go all over the
country
and see all of the great fans that's
what takes it up another notch
we got to see all of the great takes
today i'm adam lefkow
thanks for bringing them to me hot
sizzling right off the stove
really good stuff i hope that this
weekend
you guys enjoy college basketball and
that
all of the teams that you pick win
probably won't happen but then again
that's just my take